[Music]
thanks for coming yeah thanks for having
me you're like super in demand you're
real famous and you joined me on not
real that's not real it's for sure real
yes I've traveled with you all over the
country it's for sure real yeah man
people behind you like oh my gosh is
that Rachel Cruz and everyone's like
John Deone yeah they don't do that
they're like hey is that Rachel Cruz all
right so a couple things I want to talk
about today probably have some
conversations that you haven't had on
other shows that was kind of my goal but
more importantly I like it when a
podcast kind of drops in on a
conversation between two friends that
sounds like we just showed up while they
were having coffee and you and I have
done that all over the country and so y
um here's where I want to start so you
and I did this marriage event and you
and I have done it multiple times and
this time people came it was like a
weekend retreat Y and there was a bunch
of people there from all over the
country all different walks of life
engaged about to get divorced to we've
been married 34 years we're Millionaires
and we just want to see what's next for
us totally I think to a person everybody
walked away from that thing us included
like something magical happened there
and so that's rare in our world right we
we events all the time and they're great
of and they're all awesome but but
there's always like you do a tour and
there's like this particular city was
just magic and I don't know you I don't
know why it was just an energy whatever
but this was so special and unique and
so I've spent so much time just while
I'm walking in the woods just trying to
figure out what was so rad about that
weekend and one of the things you and I
have talked about that I want to unpack
a little bit is
this one of the special gifts to the
audience is is that um or in that event
was I hide my wife you hide Winston over
time or really they hide from what we do
and so one of the cool things was they
showed up yes they came out on stage yes
and it it was supposed to be like a fun
give for the audience and look at this
you get to finally meet them they're
real and she look's beautiful and
Winston's a smoke show and like here's
them when I reflect back on it and you
we read the the feedback that was some
of the most powerful that was one of the
most powerful hours of the entire
weekend yes yes and as you and I have
discussed I think it comes from this
place where they could look at you and
Winston you are a co-owner of a multi
hundreds of million dollar company your
husband is extremely successful very
talented you all both work really hard
and you all
have vast resources and then you look
over and there's me and Sheila and the
other two chairs and we have three phds
and two master's degrees between us and
I think there was a Humanity to you and
Winston
saying no marriage is real hard we're
having to figure this thing out where do
you think that illusion comes from so
that's a long setup to ask this question
where do you think this illusion comes
from that if we just had this everything
would be okay everything would be okay
and it could be money it could be all
the answers it could be all the training
it could be all the resour what does
that come
from I don't know I do feel
like specifically with us maybe and I
could be off based on this us or you and
Winston sorry us and our
jobs is cameras and microphones TVs
radio like there is a level of a
platform there and I do think with
anyone maybe except for like Hollywood
or something but you you do look at
people on and I do this for people too I
like look at I look at them whether
social media or whatever and I just
think oh my gosh okay they they look
happy for the most part right like I
know they're real people but like like
my struggle is like woo 30% 40% of the
time or whatever theirs is they probably
have some but theirs is probably like 5%
of the time and whatever that game is
that I play I associate when I see
people that I admire or respect or have
helped me personally I think oh gosh
they're doing great I know they're human
so I know there's a percentage of them
that struggles but it can't be the same
percentage that I struggle and I think
it's that barrier of like putting
someone to a degree on a pedestal and
not that people do that with us all the
time not saying like we're on this big
pedestal platform but there has to be
something about this difference because
I don't feel that way with like my good
friends right but it's enough of a is it
because you know them yeah and I guess
you just see their Humanity more on a
daily basis and I just don't think we
have the opportunity to do that all the
time right like I think about for me I'm
like I have three you know quick
episodes a week I'm on the Rams like
like my time in front of people is so
limited and it's curated and it's
curated to a degree because we can look
yeah and I and I try to be human on it I
try not to like put on a complete fake
face but I'm like but I'm not going to
pull up my phone in the middle of a
fight with Winston and be like I just
need you guys to see like I'm like
that's so inappropriate like I would
never I like that's so crazy so there is
something to me that I I will put even
me a percentage on people's struggle and
say but it surely it's less than
mine I need to put a pin in that surely
it's less than mine because that'll be
an important conversation later on um
when we talk about comparison I don't
know if that answers your question but
there's just something about that I
think it's a distance thing
maybe it's a resource
thing um I I think I I wonder if it's
hard to be in our own skin and it's just
easy to look and go I feel this way
surely they don't right and so how do I
get from here to there and the world if
you just scroll Instagram it's like well
you have to have money and you have to
buy this thing and you have to have this
thing and you have to have this thing
and you got to go get this information
listen to this podcast read this book
and it's almost I remember the audience
going
and it was almost freeing mhm or not
maybe almost maybe it was completely
freeing to go oh they don't have it all
figured out either yep we're okay yes
and that means we can all keep figuring
this out right right and I do wonder the
dynamic of that on stage you have both
couples sitting there where usually like
the people I'm thinking in my head it's
the it's the person and I know they're
married but I don't I'm not in a
conversation with their spouse or I'm
not watching that conversation happen so
I think there's like two pieces of the
puzzle of like oh wow this is this is it
and I'll give kudos to our spouses we're
very honest yeah yeah yeah you know
they're very smart and they're yeah and
that vulnerability though too I think
gave that there wasn't this like oh gosh
we have to image
management level of like you and I did
not marry image managers no we were not
image managers that weekend which I
think is what brought some of the magic
to because yeah like so what makes
marriage so hard oh
like if you had to distill it down I
have an idea or two but and I'm not even
talking about the nerd literature like
what do you think it is I feel like for
when I feel like what I've learned that
I didn't realize and I feel like I've
been my eyes have been open more in the
last probably 24 months I think 2019 was
a hard year for us and we started doing
some work and then we kind of like
ramped it up even in the last year or
two and I just don't think I realized
how much self- protection I brought into
marriage def find Self Protection
protecting my myself protecting my ego
my feelings wanting to feel safe all of
it without knowing it that's what was
that's what's waked me out about
understanding myself is I'm like all
this is subconscious it's not like your
body's protecting you you don't even
know yeah I'm like yeah and and and then
you're you know and then I'm sitting
down with my therapist and she'll say
something and she's like yeah well
that's that's little Rachel who is dying
for this and this and this and it's
coming out in a
35-year-old body and I was like
really is that what that is you know I'm
like I didn't even know that's what I
was doing and Winston the same way and
he was if he was sitting here he would
be very honest with that too like there
was something again not conscious it was
subconscious of like I just had to
protect myself and that comes out
sideways and in different ways and in
our marriage it was caretaking it was a
level of codependence all of that where
again not knowing that was happening and
then you end up in this like
dysfunctional dance and then you wake up
and you're like
wait this isn't healthy because I I mean
it's kind of working like it's you know
as one therapist said I heard they like
it works until it doesn't work right
like alcohol and cocaine they work great
yeah it's great like they kill you yeah
exactly so so yeah so I think part of
marriage that is hard is we just bring
in so much stuff you can say from
childhood or whatever and we we at the
core of us are trying we're trying to
protect ourselves always to a degree so
what have you found that you were trying
to protect What would is your body
trying to keep
safe uh and here's why I asked that
question I don't mean like deep dark
secrets I'm saying you have identified
this other person in marriage you were
my ride or die
y I'm all in and that's a CO like a
cognitive Choice I'm choosing you yes
your body goes oh no right and it kicks
up the defense 247 365 and it plays out
for a decade that way yeah right until
somebody work laughs at your jokes and
suddenly your body goes oh we can bring
our defenses down because she's safe or
he's safe or this thing happens or that
thing happens or the mailman knocked on
the door and he's really attractive like
oh my God the Christmas tree guy two
Christmas ago the Christmas tree guy
right whatever oh was he a smoke show
literally I walked I was all like
disheveled and I was like oh wow you're
actually a very good-looking Christmas
tree decorator guy are you yeah is this
like yeah he was selling like lights we
didn't even go with their company sorry
company but anyway but like
so what what was your body protecting
you from
um I think a level of not wanting to be
hurt so I can live in this um it sounds
just like paana and it's not that it
doesn't feel that shallow I'm just
naturally that the glasses have full
naturally I'm always going to like yeah
and everything's going to be okay we're
going to figure it out and that mindset
that has been in that I've found makes
life better you know Rachel 15 at in
high school if you get left out of
something it's okay it's going to be
fine it's next it's fine don't worry
about that next week like like I would
always tell myself it's G to be okay
it's G to be okay so then when when hard
stuff in marriage happens something that
boils up that I actually needed to be
like what the is going on I was like you
know what it's going to be okay it's
going to be okay and because I'm like I
don't want to feel that pain I don't
want to feel that hurt I don't want to
feel pain hurt loneliness s like all of
those I'm good it's going to be okay
because truthfully too through most of
like life it h it has like I got
friendliest up with high school like I
like I was you know like for the most
part it has played out until it starts
to not and you start to see wow this
thing that brought me through that I
thought was actually helping I think in
the long term it it harms you because
there's parts of me that I think I did
shut off to protect to make it be okay
to be okay and and the only way to a
deep powerful marriage was going through
that stuff that's not okay that's right
and it was intense we had an intense
season yeah and yet it was the
healthiest breaking that needed to
happen for both of us and that's the
sick thing too is I'm like for Wiston
and I again he I'm not telling Secrets
if he was sitting here he'd say the same
thing where we both can lean in like
codependent where some people I think
can lean very independent and protect
themselves that way we almost found the
safety in each other to an unhealthy
degree which sounds funny in marriage
cuz in my head too in marriage no it's
all okay cuz you're married you have
this label of marriage over you so all
of this is fine right until you realize
oh my gosh individually I am not a
healthy person Winston said this in
money and marriage on the panel but it's
true he was like you can't like if
you're both C+ people you can't have an
A+ marriage like that's a good like it
doesn't average out like that and so I
think for us too the protecting oh it's
going to be fine it's going to be
fine and couple that with a level of
codependence that like if you're good
I'm like we're gonna we're good like
life is good we're good we're good we're
good we're good like you live and again
it's not like once I we shallow people
we had good conversations we were
connected we did therapy together right
like I mean during some of this and like
so when I that's that's the other thing
that that's the other thing that kind of
shocked my system is I was like oh my
gosh a plus b doesn't always equal C my
therapist said that to me and I was like
it's so true like you can love Jesus you
can do all the things here you can both
do self-work and to to a degree in all
this year and somebody leaves and still
something happens like and that messed
with me John oh because life isn't an
algorithm yes and I wouldn't have said
life's an algorithm if you asked Rachel
three years ago is life an algorithm I'm
like no stuff happens all the time right
but again not to me but subconsciously I
thought yeah but if you're wise and and
not that we're not going to make unwise
decisions in right there there is a
level of you or what you so to a degree
but also some years it just doesn't rain
some years it doesn't happen so you plow
the field it perfectly and there's no
rain yes yes so it's all of that like
and so me and Sheila was detangling all
of that opposite where
hers I very much had a she's going to
leave it any minute and hers is very
much independent hers was he's going to
leave any minute but she solved that by
Independence and list and I Sol that I
solved it by trying to hang on and so we
had this like it was it was amazing and
then we'd go and this when the VIN
diagrams are AC cross right well thanks
for thanks for about that I I think
there's this idea that yeah if you just
do all the right things marriage is
perfect right and if it's not perfect
then we need to scour the Earth for all
the right things my aim is different now
and it is I'm going to do all these
things that I know in this moment to be
right and by the way I've learned in the
last five years and before that I
learned different things and before that
I had different things and all of that
does is brings me to a baseline that
gives me a chance not that it guarantees
an outcome and I think there's something
powerful about that outcome not being
guaranteed because then I got to keep
showing up and then I got to keep
showing up and that keeps me from
getting complacent it keeps me from just
phoning it in it keeps me every day
looking at Sheila like this morning I
was like how can I love you today yep
and she's like just hug me right now and
I was looking for this like gesture and
she's like just let me just hold me for
a minute yep and off those lines cuz you
said that and I was like oh my gosh it's
so true cuz I think part of the dynamic
and the formula of that of just keep
showing up all of it is showing up and
continuing to push into the pain because
I think for so long I was like oh my
gosh if that's that bad thing there or
that that's wrong or that's yeah we stay
away from that we we attach to something
else we go we go where I think I'm
learning I'm like oh no it's actually
through through the pain through the
grossness through the messiness that is
actually life like that's where it is
we're so we we avoid it and we think you
know and in the Christian circles you
could label it sin you could label it
suffering you can like all right I think
every every person has their thing and
for so long it's like nope we avoid no
where you're actually like what what is
going on in me that's causing that or
wanting that or whatever and it's
actually through that I got to like go
through it and not just say that's wrong
oh we're going to turn this way and
White Knuckle our way to be better just
hold on and to run and to go it's
actually like facing it yeah the beauty
of marriage is you hold hands with
somebody you go let's go through this
together we're headed through like I
think for so long it's like I could
identify the hard and be like oh that's
it okay yeah let's work on that let's
work on that but I think it's even I
think it's even like two layers deeper
where it's like no no no we're gonna
like go through that and and and through
it yeah I just think I I think I just
had this avoidance of not just the hard
like I feel like that even sounds like
oh it's like the hard we can avoid that
it's almost like oh no that's that that
thing's not okay and that's wrong what
over there so we're just going to turn
our backs and and and be good and and
turn that way versus being like huh
that's kind of messy right there let's
actually like sit in that talk about it
go through
it